3 juin 1950 à l'aube ils partent pour le
sommet où louis lachenal peut prendre à
8 75 mètres d'altitude cette photo qui
est en allemand maurice herzog tenant
fièrement le drapeau français
c'était le 3 juin 1950 il y a tout juste
70 ans
l'ascension de l'annapurna un sommet de
l'himalaya de 8000 75 m un acte héroïque
une première mondiale mais s'il y avait
des couacs dans ce beau roman de la
france conquérante retour quelques mois
en arrière mars 1950
les caméras sont sur le tarmac pour voir
s'envoler l'équipe d'alpinistes cinq ans
après la guerre la france a besoin de
prestige et de nouveaux héros c'est donc
maurice herzog résistant pendant la
guerre qui sera le chef de l'expédition
c'est un rôle qui m'est gzale tech je
trouve est magnifique l'expédition est
compliquée la mousson menace mais ils
l'ont fait à leur retour en [ __ ] et des
doigts pied des phalanges de la main
maurice herzog et louis lachenal les
deux seuls à être allé au sommet sont
célébrés comme des demi-dieux c'est
toute la france qui est robert serait de
cette nouvelle victoire
maurice herzog chef de l'expédition
écrire à la version officielle dans un
livre vendu à 10 millions d'exemplaires
toutes les lumières sont braqués sur lui
et sur lui seul il devient ministre de
la jeunesse et des sports
l'annapurna il a transformé cette
deuxième existence me paraît beaucoup
plus grande est beaucoup plus belle que
la première l'histoire pourrait
s'arrêter là
mais il y a comme un secret qui plane
louis lachenal son compère de cordes est
décédé cinq ans après l'ascension avait
lui aussi écrit un livre remaniée par
herzog
il faudra attendre 1996 pour que la
version non censurée soit édité
j'estimais que s'il continue est seul il
ne reviendrait pas c'est pour lui et
pour lui seul que je n'ai pas fait demi
tour
ce serait donc ça la vraie version de
l'exploit herzog poussé par un alpinisme
nationaliste oblige son guide à mettre
leur vie en danger car zaugg n'ira mais
la polémique ne s'arrête pas là en 2012
félicité herzog sa propre fille
le décrit dans un roman comme un homme
orgueilleux et arriviste ce qui lui fait
douter de son exploit je formule une
hypothèse selon laquelle il aurait 50 m
100 m avant d'atteindre le sommet décidé
de faire demi tour à cause de la mousson
cette expédition avait pour but de créer
un héros de redorer l'image de la france
le héros a été créé mais aujourd'hui
soixante dix ans après le mystère plane
toujours pour savoir ce qu'il s'est
réellement passé lors de l'ascension de
l'annapurna le 3 juin 1950
c